I was lucky enough to actually host an HBO panel
where you and I in depthly spoke about
your process in "The Undoing."
And I was wondering if you would tell us
about how you treated this character
in defining the multi-facets of him.
I do remember that I have felt
I was playing two characters.
And that they were both real.
Obviously the most real was guilty Jonathan,
who was a sociopath.
Narcissistic sociopath who only really loved himself.
And couldn't love anyone else,
couldn't feel for anyone else
and who is capable of killing
without feeling even a smidgen of remorse.
But there was also innocent Jonathan,
the Jonathan who presented himself to the world.
And he wasn't exactly a lie
because Jonathan had convinced himself
that that was really the real him.
And that it was not even conceivable
that this great doctor, this great healer of children,
this wonderful father, this wonderful husband,
this charming man about Manhattan
could possibly be a killer.
So all those five and a half episodes
I spend in that series saying,
"I'm, I didn't kill her.
I didn't kill her.
I may have been a little unfaithful, but I didn't kill her.
And I love you."
He believes all that.
And it was very important that he does believe it
because, you know, all the evidence pointed to my guilt
and to preserve the whodunit aspect of that series,
I needed to be convincing when I was denying my guilt.
I love it.
And a true sociopathic narcissist, if you've studied them,
that is the exact behavior.
Yeah, they believe their lies.
They create their own narrative
and they're, and it's infallible.
And the only thing that snowballs for them
is further truth actually, upon the lies.
So you can't even peel back the layers to get to the truth.
You just get so far and it just happens to be
a character trait I studied profusely
and I was just so-
Which boyfriend or husband was like that?
(audience laughs)
(Drew coughs coyly)
I'll tell you where the cameras aren't rolling.
But yeah, I'm, listen, I know.
And also, you know, there's a huge amount
that goes in the political game of sociopathic narcissism.
It falls into gas lighting.
There's an extraordinary amount of behavior
that occurs from one human being
in a position of power,
or a family member
that does put on a charade that puts other people
in a washing machine.
And it's a very different.
To me, the common denominator
in all those people is narcissism.
It's incredible self love.
And you see it a lot in show business.
But you see it a lot in politics.
Which of course some people say
is show business for the ugly.
(audience claps and cheers)
(Drew laughs)
I've never heard that one before,
but I'll never forget it.
Well, Hubert.
I just think my lucky stars that I get to know you
and that I still know you,
and I'm so happy for your family and your life,
and just everything that you've given to us.
And I love that you're sassy and curmudgeony.
And just send Hubert kisses off into the air.
To you and your five beautiful children
and your sexy mean, which you need probably,
beautiful wife.
(audience laughs)
(Hugh chuckles)
Yeah.
Well, it's been lovely to see you Drew.
I'll see you in the, what was it called?
The Waverly Inn.
But behave yourself.
I'll meet you at the Waverly Inn, baby.
HBO's original series "The Undoing"
is streaming now on HBO max.
(upbeat music plays)